sciencedaily from science mission a new  study using human induced pluripotent  stem cell-derived astrocytes from  costello syndrome attributes human  intellectual disability to excessive  extracellular matrix remodeling factors  and proteoglycans resulting in excessive  astrocyte to neuronal signaling next  researchers found a new mechanism for  the survival of immune cells called  memory t-cells that fights against  viruses and it involves interleukin 7  interleukin 7 induces expression of  glycerol channel for glycerol import  resulting in fatty acid esterification  and triglyceride synthesis and storage  which finally increases ATP synthesis  for the survival next scientists show  that trna derived fragments from trna  during hypoxia binds to RNA binding  proteins displacing them from multiple  oncogenic transcripts thereby reducing  tumor metastasis for more details visit  us www.lend our science mission facebook  page